hey what's up everyone it's gerald and
today we have something really special
as you can tell from the title of the
video we'll be checking out intel's
latest 12th generation cpus thanks to
the folks at intel aftershock asus and
corsair we have a custom rig all built
we'll be putting this beast through a
few benchmark tests and games as well it
screams rgb and is totally made for
gaming at the heart of it all is intel's
12th generation i7 12 700 cpu and to
pair along with this is rg's brand new
z690 motherboard it's plenty of
thunderbolt ports usb ports wi-fi 6e and
glorious rgb as well and on top of that
we have the latest ddr5 ram pretty much
there's no bottlenecks in this and it's
all going to be small sailing from here
but whether or not it really lines up to
the test let's check out the benchmark
scores and we're gonna do some gaming on
it as well because as we know these days
when it comes to benchmark scores i
think the processor and the motherboard
they know how to play the game but what
actually reflects in real world
performance is where it really matters
so let's get into it guys
we're gonna get hardware info in once
again to see if
all the processes here
are running cool what the temperature is
looking like and we have been idle for
quite some time here if you can look at
the
numbers here it's okay actually looking
pretty cool across the board we are
talking about average temps about 25
to as high as 74 this is actually pretty
normal in some ways and in the previous
generation we can see temperatures going
as high as 90 on average so so far so
good when it comes to idle but clearly
that's not the real test okay for a
start let's get into the first important
thing here and that would be 3dmark time
to run the time and tested time spy i
think everyone's very familiar with this
let's go with it and see how it performs
in terms of the numbers-wise okay time
spy has run the processor through its
paces and let's look at the numbers
we're looking about 13 13
799 score here take those numbers and
tell us how does this actually figure
out against what you're expecting from
the new processors look at all this
there's no we're not we're not faking
the numbers here it is running on the
new 12th gen intel core i7
12 700 kf and we have the nvidia
geforce rtx 3070. looking through all
these numbers here fps wise graphically
it's looking pretty much what we really
expected i think we can really push this
even more when it comes to gaming
cpu score we're looking at about 16 721
and a cpu test of 56 fps
make it of what you will of these
numbers guys with 3d mark out of the way
this is the big number that we'll be
looking out for when it comes to the
benchmark scores so
keep this number in mind when you're
comparing it to other processors in the
market and let's go on to cinebench
before we actually go into cinebench
we're looking at the temperatures here
once again
guys the temperatures don't even seem to
be budging at all it's insane it's
really running really cool
the the highest that we can look at
right now 62 degrees celsius that's
actually pretty low guys compared to
what we can tell in the previous
generation we're talking about hitting
temperatures about 90 when it comes to
such performances okay now we're in
cinebench once again and we have quite a
few benchmarks here with all the other
processors in the market
that being said let's go for multi-core
and let's go start
man the rendering is looking pretty fast
we can hear this fan speeding up quite a
bit can you hear this you know
you're speaking my silent earlier right
but right now
i think cinebench is really pushing this
uh gpu cpu to its limits
but
it's still okay it's a very gentle hum
not too it's not like yeah not like a
plane taking off
it's rendering here and past one
boom that looks pretty good
how's it looking at right now
you can see that is hitting a score
about
21 000 very close to 22k do we have we
can't really connect this to the
internet because we don't have the
benchmark scores at this point we can't
leak anything this is under embargo at
the time of recording here so take these
numbers and let us know what do you
think of these numbers here last one
we're going to put it through would be
superposition benchmark and we're going
to see how that really does well when it
comes to another benchmark test preset
wise i think we can do even more 4k
optimize let's see how superposition
benchmark really pushes this processor
to its limits we're looking at 4k
optimize and let's give it a go okay
guys we've just finished the super
position benchmark and we're looking at
a 4k optimized test we're looking we're
pushing very close to 11k here we can
compare results online because these
numbers are still under embargo so take
note of these numbers guys we'll be
playing quite a few titles here starting
off with doom we're going to chivalry
forza gangshin impact and of course
we're laurent as well
it's a good cross section of the titles
that you'll be checking out and be
playing on this rig after all it's a
very modest rig especially 3070 very
attainable for most folks
together and paired with the brand new
intel 12th generation cpu with that
being said let's get into it all right
so here at premiere pro we've already
created a one minute file of 8k files
no prores no nothing on the side should
just stand it
8k video
you can see on
uh screen here
it's 8k files at 30.
we rendered maximum depth the bit rate
we're gonna keep at 50
and it's just one minute of video and
our expected estimated file size is 377
megabytes you did some tweaks earlier
about putting it to software and to
hardware software encoding right so for
software encoding
i'm gonna be disabling uh the
gpu course the geforce cuda course and
we're just gonna
this should if i'm not wrong and please
correct me in the comments if i'm not
wrong
uh once we pick software encoding
it's just gonna run the cpu and the ram
with not much of the gpu so
yeah let's uh run it out and see how
long it takes
and let's go
alright so
few minutes has passed
still quite surprised because
on
like i'm using previous generation cpu
and
it's not as smooth sailing
as this and it's handling 8k really
really well it's brand new after all
my new this is not like the heaviest
thing we can do
but it's just a real world test
yeah
do let us know in the comments down
below if you want us to
you know perhaps try after effects
render
some motion graphics and things like
that but i think
for what it's worth
if any of you are doing 8k footage this
is going to
make your life a lot more easier yeah we
are now in doom eternal and we're going
to go through into the settings to see
how this weighs up in our test itself
we're going under video vsync is off so
we can achieve maximum frames if
possible
uh retracing is off as well dlss quality
let's see how it goes and obviously when
it comes to advanced overall quality of
this game we're putting it on ultra
nightmare this is the highest where we
have gone
guys
let's go on into the game and try out
their brand new hot mode and we are in
the game now guys
space to continue
on into the game and try out their brand
new hot mode okay looking good 92 fps
let's get going
73 fps the most important thing you'll
be looking for here guys is actually how
hot this system actually runs over time
and if it really works out
against when everything starts to appear
on screen boom
70 fps staying nice and smooth
mcl oops i missed my aim
ah
it's super sensitive
and it's looking pretty good stable fps
frames you can't really see it move that
much
it's
turning up pretty well guys let's take
out this guy here
come on
man you load up
chainsaw
load up once again
let's go down let's go down okay guys
we've made it to the end of the first
wave when it comes to doom eternal
itself it's looking pretty good
constant fps no issues at all let's go
check out the temperatures
temperatures wise if you're looking here
that is looking awesome no problem at
all for this that means there's plenty
of headroom to go even though we are
pushing this to its limits as much as we
can what else do we have we have genjin
impact okay
let's go to settings first oh yeah i
know we're gonna get into things okay
and
graphics
high or default okay no problem at all
problem fps is 60
he sync off off
when the solution
yeah
it doesn't even count i don't know
that's good yeah hi hi hi hi anthony
[Music]
motion extreme
kardashian
okay
okay so let's get straight into the game
it's looking very smooth so far looking
very smooth and i'm looking at the cpa
utilization only twenty three percent no
problem
i mean we can't go any higher when it
comes to this game because fps is pretty
much capped at 60 fps let's go into a
dungeon and a mission to see how it
actually goes up with all the flying all
the effects are flying about you only
play this on uh pc actually
i put on pc but the thing is like um i
was doing my laptop back then before i
got my pc
and
it's not as smooth as this i think we're
going easy on the
cpu guys
way too
this is way too easy
okay i think this is too easy
yeah
we're switching out you're switching out
zeke you've been playing this game a lot
let's see video
all right everything is on epic
cpu utilization is only at twenty
percent are you even testing the cpu
i think
the only thing that could really stress
it out was the
benchmarks and itself was looking pretty
good she didn't want to just throw this
beer
[Laughter]
stable very good
good thing
the rss helps has helped
start the door
all right next game nice game thanks
again okay so over here in the velour
menu and everything has been set to
the highest fps is unkept fbi limited
fps always it's off
graphics quality multi-third rendering
on high high high everything's on high
vsync is off and the air since the fx
aea
this corporate yeah and this dropping
that thing
is 16.
after that yeah i think we're good to go
for a game it's looking good yeah i
can't tell you okay no
they're all going to
this is the pro
pro gameplay guys this is this is how do
you play valor without sound no this is
how you dream of lauren you know
gallery of lauren it's all about
instinct
so yeah let's just
they're looking here
cpu utilization is that 25
oh nice
yeah let's just
they're looking here
cpu utilization is that 25
whoa
whoa surprise
i'm an idiot
one
i mean i wanted to be funny but it's
okay okay so uh lord
amazing pretty damn well i mean
obviously like you're talking about
optimization and everything so maybe
that's why the cpu utilization was
pretty high i mean let's go to huawei
info and take a look at the temperature
for temperatures wise wow valerian's
heating this thing up the highest we've
seen so far but average price is still
40 which is still pretty good i mean for
60 also it honestly isn't that high
we're expecting times normally about 90.
yeah like 100 but this is actually doing
pretty well yeah 65 and it's max
awesome well done intel
okay that being said let's go on and try
forza falls out all right so jumping the
settings on the basic tab here we are
running this at 4k draw it of course
foreign is unlocked
v-sync is off hopping into advance
these are settings
now
based on photo games
they've already
kind of optimized it for you so i'm
going to leave it on default
um
because honestly it looks good it looks
good yeah
so save and continue
jumping in
fps is maxing out at 160 fps here
jumping into it wow cpu utilization is
going up but nothing too stressful
we are still hitting 150
140 150.
44 a small little brief moment otherwise
not an issue
that went a little bit busy went down 1
30. i believe
but
yes wise
looking good 155
tighten
boop clipped a bit
oh look at that color man
just the shading and the reflections
coming out the color
points are more
so much pretty much action is a bit
light so
there's no
[Music]
are we pushing in any way no frames are
still good
yeah and cpu utilization 25 even in this
state
okay when the lead now awesome
23 percent frames are still going good
thank you what do you think
i think overall nmes including the other
games i think it's more of the gpu load
but
what i can tell from
from testing out the cpu
is that
everything is just
more responsive
i mean
you have to see
all the components as one complete
ecosystem
and the cpu itself
helps with
how do i how do i say it
it just puts it all together nicely
yeah all right guys it's amazing yeah
like your cpu and the processing when
you put an app of course that's also
have to do with the ssd but
the cpu is basically managing all of
these processes
and i'm pretty sure if we alternate that
right now you won't be like have any
like freezing or anything okay just why
don't you try that
other than that
temperatures wise the highest oh this is
the highest we've actually seen eighty
percent
80 degrees celsius actually
we've left premiere pro on the
background it's not going to be smooth
scrubbing but
dude this is this itself is really
very good
in fact you can you can scrub a little
bit
so this i know definitely when it comes
to speed scrubbing like this and like
playback
i'm pretty sure even in full
come on
come on okay a little bit of freeze
there
why can't you hear the fans going oh
wow okay so maybe not in full maybe not
in it for about half resolution
and mind you like i have the same gpu
but just just the previous processor and
i had to run it at 108
okay
then i think we've put the intel
pretty much through spaces yep let's
give our final thoughts
okay now we have put the intel 12
generation through its paces i think
what we've seen here is pretty much very
impressive from the folks at intel after
all the 12th generation cpu is running
cooler and with less power consumed as
well that means there's plenty of hit
room for developers to really push this
cpu to its limits after all it's pretty
impressive looking by the numbers here
and we're talking real world specs here
guys
this is what we are seeing on the very
middle of the road type of build we're
not talking about the top end specs
because after all this we are looking at
i7 12700 cpu here and paired together
with a very
i would say very modest 3070 gpu as well
if you made it this far thank you so
much for watching through this video
follow us on all our socials and leave
us a subscribe and a like if you haven't
the most important thing at this point
of time is that the entire 12th
generation cpus there might be plenty of
questions that you might have that we
have not covered in this video so leave
them all in the comment section below
and we'll try our best to answer them as
much as possible with that being said
this is gerald signing off